right
uh welcome to this extraordinary meeting
of cabinet uh members of cabinet
so without further ado do we have any
apologies for absence out
we do we have apologies from councillor
cargill and councillor juned
thank you one
so we now move on to matters to be
referred to council on monday
uh which is the proposal to create the
south warwickshire district council
i should remark that we had a four-hour
meeting of the overview and scrutiny
looking at this
you all have
uh
an immense award of papers
so what i'm going to try and do is just
run through
pretty much what i said to overview and
scrutiny on
tuesday
first and most obvious thing
this is a major strategic decision
it's almost certainly the biggest
decision we as councillors will have to
make
and we need to focus very clearly on the
strategic issues
one of the things i would say is that
this is not a comparison
of the south warwickshire council versus
the current
stratfor district council and warwick
district council
it's about the future for a south
warwickshire district council
against the future for separate
stratford and warwick district councils
uh why are we actually looking at a
merger
well it's actually fairly simple
the the initial driver very clearly was
the financial position of both councils
and the need to make savings
the financial background leaves little
room for maneuver for individual
councils
on top of that covid has exacerbated the
pressures
the alternatives to a merger
are quite simple it's either cut
services
very severely
or keep spending to the point where
we get a section 114 notice
from our illustrious section 151
officers sitting at the back
and then probably a commissioner to make
the cuts the councillors should
otherwise have done
what i would say is
that an awful lot of councils are
burying their heads in the sand over the
financial position some of them councils
not too far away
we are seeking to take control of our
own destiny which i think is important
i would also add that given the
financial pressures on councils across
the country
this decision could well be of national
significance
and for a benchmark for what other
councils may seek to do
a lot of people will be watching us
i would also stress it will be over two
years before the new council comes into
existence
and a lot can happen in two years as
we've seen with the coveted outbreak
over the last two
i would also say that the economic
picture is challenging
there's unlikely to be a great deal of
additional support from central
government
which intensifies the need for merger
we will be far better able to tackle
these pressures
as a south warwickshire council
there is a view
that we can merge services but not merge
politically
personally i think that is a very
unstable
option
we've got the experience of the south
warwickshire sorry of warwickshire
police and west mercier and that does
not build well
uh as one of my illustrious cabinet
colleagues said
uh one body and two heads does not work
terribly well
so just a word about the open survey
because an awful lot of people get hung
up on the numbers on the survey
as i said on tuesday
uh in the papers as a total electorate
of 217
426 there were 1441
personal responses
to the survey the open survey that is
point seven percent of the electorate
0.7
i would also say there is a long way to
go
even after the vote that's taken on
monday
and there's an awful lot of detailed
work that will need to be done
there's a lot of issues that we cannot
settle before the decision
and a lot of issues not under our
control
the number of councillors being won
we meet the three tests set by
government that is pretty clear
i will repeat what i said initially
this is a strategic decision for
councillors
and i would stress that is it is a
decision for us as counselors
and the question a lot of people may
need to consider
is what are the alternatives for
addressing the issues we face
at one level
this is a very
difficult and complex set of issues
but at its heart it boils down to a very
very simple decision
and that is
where do you think
the best
future for our residents lies the south
warwickshire district council or
separate stratford and warwick district
council
i think from what i've said i mean my
view would be
it is pretty obvious what the answer
should be
so that introduces
quite succinctly i think an awfully long
paper some members of cabinet any
comments or observations
thank you mr chairman um
the papers we've been presented with uh
are in
some ways very similar to a
very very very very lengthy planning
application
with a single exception there's no
officer recommendation
the paper summarizes the arguments but
doesn't come to a conclusion quite
rightly so
but the evidence that's presented is
comprehensive
if you liken the papers uh to statutory
console teams to your planning
application
there is no
well if there is i didn't find any
single
um
person or body that was consulted in any
sense
that said anything other than they had
no objection to this this proposal and
in fact there are others who were warmly
in support
so the the question for me is
this is a paper which
in all if you read it from start to
finish the conclusion you have to come
to is that had the officers been
required to put a recommendation the
recommendation would have been to
approve this proposal
and if that is not the case i would be
very very very very interested to hear
the counter arguments
just to emphasize the point that you
make this is a decision it's not a
popularity contest it's not a referendum
this is a decision for 36 councils of
sdc to make
and
my final point is that in making that
decision
those councillors who make that decision
are acting as district
councillors they are not representatives
of any other body let alone a parish
council
their view may be the same as the parish
council their view may be different from
a parish council but their their
responsibility is to make a decision
that's in the best interests of the
district and the district's future
thank you councillor harvey some very
powerful points there
councillor parry
thank you thank you leader um well
firstly i'd actually like to express my
thanks to all the teams that have been
involved in producing this
very comprehensive and well-honed
document
which not only represented hours of
reading but it also represents hours and
hours of work which has been undertaken
i believe with great diligence and a
forensic approach
with no stone unturned
i'm actually fully
i'm fully in support of the proposed
merger
as i believe the positives far outweigh
the negatives
there are always downsides as well as
positives to a merger
i happened to merge my pr consultancy
back in 1997
um
and then actually sold it further 10
years later
so i feel i have real coal face
experience of what's involved in a
merger and the importance of both
communications and bringing two very
different sides together to form one
unit
no mergers are easy
and i think what we have is some very
important facts on this one
in that we do have the backing of the
chief executives
and his senior management team together
with the majority of staff and i believe
that is a critical success factor that
is required
whilst one does need to recognize there
is this current gap between council tax
of stratfor district council and warwick
district council of around 27 pounds i
think it's important to highlight
the increases we've already paid this
year
to warwickshire county council
a matter of 72 pounds
for a d-grade property and in fact 15
pounds on a d-grade property to
warwickshire police
which represents 87 pounds increase
increase which is actually nearly 60
percent of our total of our total sdc
council tax
um for a great property d property this
this year
so i think you know
yes there will always be queries on on
the council tax differential but you
only have to see what we've had to pay
extra just in itself to warwickshire
county council and in fact warwickshire
police
i feel the benefits certainly are
considerable there are actually far too
many for me to mention but i think there
are a few that stick with me
um
and that would be joining joining forces
with warwickshire warwick district
council would bring considerable
benefits in terms of
access to affordable housing in the
district
i think from a workforce point workforce
point of view a super district offers
much greater level
of development for members of staff we
have a greater pool of skills
there are greater opportunities
and it's a greater opportunity to retain
the excellent staff we have
i think our attention should be more
focused towards the focus groups because
actually they had a much better
opportunity to get
under the skin and really understand the
issues
um
we also have a number of parish and town
councillors that have recognised the
potential
of improved economies of scale
and and i was particularly pleased that
wells form has
voiced their support
and represents the majority of residents
that
i have in my ward area i also think from
a climate change perspective the
opportunity
to with the introduction of hybrid
working which clearly is going to
continue we then have the opportunity of
cost savings but also to improve our
carbon footprint by rationalizing the
buildings we operate in so basically in
a nutshell it's a no-brainer for me and
i'm i'm very much in support of these
proposals and wish to extend my thanks
to everyone who's been involved in
putting together such a comprehensive
document thank you chair
thank you councillor parry and i do know
to your thanks to the people who put
this document together and i would echo
your view that it is an excellent
document
uh very long
uh councillor jennings
councillor shenton thank you chairman we
are elected to make hard decisions and
we've we've been elected to read
documents like this
and all that all the rest of it
and we've all spent our time and we have
we have read all of these documents
to me it makes financial sense indeed a
financial necessity
and i think it's in the best interest of
everyone in both districts
um i'm very much in favor of the merger
and i also agree with those wise words
one body cannot have two heads
thank you councillor jennings and as you
were first to utter those wide wise
words i think your comments are
appropriate councillor shenton
thank you leader i just wanted to talk
briefly about the the survey itself
um
i mean you can pick
pieces of data and information out the
survey to support any argument that's
the nature of
surveys
and no survey is ever going to capture
all the thoughts fears opportunities can
only be a guide
but something that does come through
is that the key area of concern to
businesses and to residents
from the survey is is that of showing
leadership
and accountability
and that's what we're being asked to do
show leadership on this
so not everyone's going to be happy
that's inevitable
as you always hear more from those
opposed
than in favor because many people just
want the leaders to make those decisions
so we have to decide what's best
for our residents businesses and
district overall
or to use the government the wording the
government uses in the round
there's been a number of comments about
the inherent risk in merging but the
inherent risk of not merging in my
opinion is far far greater
doing nothing
as well is to go backwards
so i'm very much in favor i have a long
list of things i'm not going to go
through all of my points today um
because you know where i stand on this
i'm very much in favor of this and we
have to make that decision
thank you councillor shenton
and i would absolutely endorse the point
you made that we actually have to show
leadership i think that was a very very
pertinent comment
i see no other members of
i have seen no other members of province
until councillor kettle put his hand up
thank you mr chairman yeah i mean i
think
as you pointed out in the beginning this
is a strategy
there will be bridges that we have to
cross between now and any completion of
the strategy
which will involve a huge amount of
additional work by
officers
principally but also members
so um you know
i also support this strategy moving
forward
um and uh but we do need to acknowledge
there's a lot of work to do
great
so i see no other counselors wishing to
speak please
oh councillor o'donnell yes
the doctor leader this is simply to
feedback from the
um lengthy ofc meeting we had on tuesday
so
the osc scrutiny of the report was based
around five themes and our feedback on
each of those themes
the first one was consultation and the
osc welcomed the consultation exercise
and felt that we think that it was
important that this was made accessible
through the council's website
point two in our second theme was
finance and risk there were some
concerns expressed about ensuring that
all of the potential savings were
achievable
especially in the area of democracy and
office costs
the process of leveling up council tax
between the two authorities would cause
concern and this would need additional
careful consideration
it was felt that training on the
potential for the hra to cover the whole
of south warwickshire area would be
valuable
this third theme was around services and
members need to be clear about the
benefits of the merger and what it will
bring to residents and parishes
and we felt the merger would give the
opportunity to look at more innovative
delivery of services and improving
service resilience
and we also noted that when recommending
the number of councillors for the new
council
that we need to ensure that there are
sufficient councillors to operate the
number of committees that will be
required to effectively operate the
merged organization
our fifth theme was our climate
emergency
it was reported that a single entity
would be better placed to deliver a
consistent program to address climate
change
and then generally our sixth comment was
that the osc acknowledged that to date
what had been produced was a useful
framework but there's much detailed work
to be done to turn this into an
operational council and we'd also like
to express our thanks to the officers
and all those involved in producing such
a detailed and interesting
set of papers for us to peruse before
our osc meeting
thank you council o'donnell
so
in that case there's no one else uh has
indicated a wish to speak and we'll turn
to the recommendations on page one
we have three recommendations to the
cabinets
i am proposing that we accept those
recommendations members of cabinet
sorry mr brooklyn leader in relation to
the third recommendation you need to
determine so unless you're coming onto
that which whether you do uh recommend
that the council makes a formal
submission so as councilman harvey
mentioned it it's helped you determine
the recommendation on that one
we are determining from the comments
that i've heard around the cabinet table
we do wish to make a formal submission
we wish to recommend to council that the
formal
submission should be made am i correct
agreed so
can i have a second for the first three
points on recommendations cabinet
council of shenton
sorry councillor pemberton uh can i have
your approval members of cabinet
agreed thank you
recommendations to uh council
uh four five six and seven
sorry
those are councils so we don't need
determined to do that
in that case
and in fact i was wrong they are four
five six seven and eight
so
in that case
we don't need vote on that am i correct
mr grafton
in that case correct members of cabinet
meeting
no urgent business
you